hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge no it has not been that long
wow
okay then all right so it's been a
little while but i'm back home after
filming in space with markiplier and i
can't wait to get back to making videos
again and also have you heard about this
it's not backwards flipping in your
brains it's called distractible all i
gotta say is that you better know what
this is or else i'm gonna come find you
it's a little something that bob wade
and i made where we share funny stories
and laugh together there's a link in the
description if you like laughing you'll
like this anyway i'm gonna play
some videos here because it's been a
while since i've laughed
i have no joy in my soul as i've said
many times screw you i have a lot of joy
in my soul i just got done filming an
amazing project that i can't wait for
you to see i'm very happy so that should
lead to maybe
god i can't i can't i can't talk am i
glad he's frozen in there and that we're
out here and that he's the sheriff and
that we're frozen out here and that
we're in there and i just remembered
we're out here what i want to know is
where's the caveman
[Music]
not funny
think that's funny i'ma laugh if you
guys left
but not in the hot hot way in a haha
your sad way
that wasn't me editing the video that
was an actual that was the next video
interesting um there's some scottish
people that kind of say purple
purple
purple bug
purple bugler alarm
purple
bulgarian bulb what is he trying to say
purple burglar alarm
purple burglar alarm i have no idea
these are incredibly unfunny and anyone
that laughs at that is a fool
a fool
[Music]
it's not funny it's not funny not funny
not funny multiple teenagers having sex
in a school bathroom during the school
day the incident report says there was
one girl inside the bathroom and 25 boys
were seen going in and out of that
bathroom oh that that girl been doing
that ever since middle school like
i guess it got out of hand when the
teachers found out been doing any family
her mama did it her grandma did it my
grandma even know about her what's the
white girl [ __ ] that's the uh
white white voice yes jessica whitehorse
nash they all get caught [ __ ] in
classrooms all of them that is one
lordang triflin ass family
way back in the day
her great great grandma
is the reason
rosa parks sat in the front of the bus
because she was back there sucking
rachel polanski abc7
could you pay me in advance
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
shut up
shut up shut up jonah it's time to a
pump pump pump see
place the pump inside your creepy
goblin's flesh popping out your creepy
pull brown petroleum jelly
princess
i was wiping some [ __ ] off boss
[Music]
exiting narrator
see
what the [ __ ]
exiting narrator
[Music]
ah god
i don't know what the hell happened it
was amazing
[Music]
that's good
hey
it's your reflection you idiot
so now i'm in the battle city
and uh i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
this [ __ ] right here
it's always better to go second because
you can't attack on your first turn all
right [ __ ] that's great
what are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's fantastic i have potato blood in
my veins
i'm sorry what
my life is potato
in your
your working life and your living
it's always potatoes i dream of potatoes
when we are going to harvest in your
mind and in your heart you feel that you
are going to export that potatoes and
you are not going to see it anymore
that helped
the family thinks always from morning to
evening about the potatoes
what
i mean man
what a happy life and how simple life
must be
but what
they push me on and face me
[Music]
hmm from now on when you whisper i will
whisper oh you're a dirty [ __ ]
god
oh my god alexa i'd rather
fart for me
okay here's big fart oh sh
that was a deep one oh yeah
another fart sound yeah give me another
one come on
[Music]
i'm not gonna laugh to a fart joke
i adamantly refuse
[Music]
okay
in my throat
[Music]
what mic do you use it sounds great
i don't know
[Music]
you know if you solve there's a 7 000
jackpot go ahead shaggy and scooby-doo
whoa
wow
that's crazy that's crazy
i have just one thing to say to you
why that one
god why that one has this pathetic one
that's not funny nothing to say to you
[ __ ] that's so stupid that's so stupid
that's [ __ ] stupid that's stupid
that's stupid i was weakened that's the
[ __ ] thing i was weakened i was
weakened and that video
that video caught me when i was not
ready which is [ __ ] hey thanks so
much for watching this episode of uh the
try not to laugh challenge i lost again
but then again i went until i would lose
or i tried to lose i just like looking
at funny videos hey if you want more
funny stuff remember this thing that i
told you about the beginning
distractible which is in the link in the
description below if you click the link
in the description below you can laugh
too if you come to this one you could
try to you could try not to i dare you i
dare you to try not to laugh anyway
link's in the description thank you i'm
now home i can't wait for you to see in
space with markiplier but it's going to
be a little bit i'm going to give you
some more teasers of it very soon and
videos are going to be resuming back to
normal starting today or tomorrow but
whenever the hell this comes out so
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye